so which of the following numbers is a
greater
one third or one fifth
pause this video and try to answer that
all right now let's think about this
together and the way that i can best
think about it is by visualizing them so
let's imagine a hole
so
this is a hole
right over there
and then let's say that this is another
hole right over there i'm going to try
to make these rectangles about looking
about the same
and now how would i represent a third
well i would divide this hole into three
equal sections and so i'm going to try
to divide it into three equal sections
so there's three equal sections right
over there or they're supposed to be
three equal sections these are hand
drawn so give me a little slack
but one of these three equal sections
well that's one third so that is one
one-third
right over there
now what about one-fifth
well then i would try to divide this
into five equal sections
so
one
two
three
four and five equal sections and so
one-fifth would be just one of these
fifths
so it would be
that right over there so when you
compare it like this what's larger
one-third or one-fifth and if it isn't
obvious just yet i could
drag this one over
so that we can compare them
so that we can compare them directly and
you can see very clearly that one-third
it covers more of the whole it's a
larger fraction of the whole than
one-fifth is so one-third is greater
than one-fifth and so you might have
noticed an interesting pattern or might
start thinking about a pattern you might
have been tempted when you saw the five
here five is larger than three but
one-fifth is less than one-third or
one-third is greater than one-fifth and
that is generally true that the larger
the denominator the smaller the fraction
is going to be why is that because
you're dividing your whole into more
equal chunks so if you're only dividing
to three if it's one of three of the one
third of the hole or if it's one of
three equal chunks of the whole it's
going to be bigger than one of five
equal chunks of the whole
and so based on this how would you
compare these two numbers
how would you compare
two thirds
to two fifths
well same idea here
a third is bigger than a fifth so
two-thirds is definitely going to be
bigger than two-fifths and you could see
it here two-thirds
is that
while two-fifths
is that right over there
and i can do another example where i
haven't even drawn it out
how would you compare
4
over
6
to
4
over 8. so 4 6 versus 4 8.
well same idea a sixth is larger than an
eighth one-sixth is greater than
one-eighth because the denominator here
is smaller we have the same numerator
but the denominator is smaller so four
of the bigger things is going to be
larger than four of the smaller things
so 4 6 is greater than 4 8.